"﻿Typical" is a word I never use at Google in any context.
We currently have over 900 students in our internship program.
They can come through in the winter or the fall, the spring or the summer.
We ask people to do at least three months here in their internship.
We feel that gives them the best knowledge base of what a full-time employee does here,...
...which is the goal of our internship program.
I was an intern here at Google in the summer of 2006...
...and then I returned full-time January 2007.
I was in the software engineering department.
And as an intern, I got to work on improving one of the products...
...that they were working on at the time.
It was really exciting,...
...live code, actual work that would end up in production here at Google.
I was an intern and it's still in production now.
The two main areas are engineering and non-engineering.
The requirements are very different depending on the position that you are interning in.
As a general rule, we require people to be flexible, incredibly smart and creative,...
...work in a team environment.
For engineering, most of our interns have a computer science background,...
...applied math background, know at least one coding language...
...if they're going to work in development.